when it comes to self-directed study in
the field of philosophy there are some
thinkers that I would say are just
unavoidable if you want to be even
decently well read and Renee Descartes
is definitely one of them so when we're
talking about why read Descartes in the
first place well this is one of the main
motivations if you want to say that you
have studied even in a cursory way in
the history of ideas in philosophy you
really do have to engage with at least
one of his Works maybe the discourse
maybe the meditations maybe even the
passions of the Soul as we'll talk about
and you know I don't think that you can
say this of every philosopher or even of
most philosophers but his his importance
his influence influence is so massive
that even if you were going to take like
a world philosophy sort of perspective
and you know pick like
10 or 20 thinkers from all of history
there's a good reason for putting
Descartes in there at least you know
some engagement with this guy's ideas
because he he's so Central to philosophy
and some of the themes that he's
bringing up are you know so very
interesting he's making contributions
not only in other fields like
mathematics but in metaphysics in
epistemology
in part in ethics in the theory of the
emotions in thinking about the nature of
human rationality and how we differ from
animals and machines so there is an
argument that can be made there let's
just call it massive influence argument
and that's one reason why you definitely
would want to study Renee Descartes and
his works
I would also say that there's something
like let's call it an aesthetic Motif as
well he's a great writer very clear at
least in parts and his style is
wonderful and sometimes even witty it's
tough to make jokes that last the test
of time but Descartes has in fact done
that
and I find you know the more that you
read his works at least for me the more
engaging they become there's there's
certain philosophers as well as many
other people whose Works reward reading
and re-reading I first read Descartes
for uh you know my classes I would say
over 30 years ago
and I've read and re-read some of his
Works many times over I even had a
graduate level course on Descartes which
was really quite wonderful with a
professor named Andrew black and you
know we had to read a lot of his work
for a preliminary examinations and then
I found myself teaching him semester
after semester as a matter of fact any
time that I teach an introduction to
philosophy class Descartes is in there
at least one of his his work sometimes I
smuggle both the discourse and the uh uh
meditations in there so that tells you
you know if my experience is relevant to
your experience at all
um maybe the first reading the second
reading the third reading won't be quite
as rewarding but if you if you continue
with it you will find that it is quite
worthwhile and the two of these kind of
dovetail together this massive
importance influence Motif and the
aesthetic Motif many other people have
been attracted to Descartes since he
came on the scene and he provides a
bunch of reference points that you
really do want to know about so I think
those are probably sufficient reasons
for why you should incorporate Renee
Descartes into any course of
self-directed study in philosophy that
you plan on doing
with a figure like Renee Descartes
you're not going to have any trouble
finding texts and translations of his
works as a matter of fact we could talk
about an embarrassment of riches there
are so many translations into English as
well as into so many other languages you
might wonder well which translation do I
have to start with we'll talk about that
in a bit I do want to say that you could
probably go to any well-stocked public
library or you can find all sorts of
things online of course you can go to
you know sites or places that specialize
in the great books and you're going to
find some of Descartes works and he's
been translated a number of times
interestingly some of his Works were
actually translated into French and you
might say whoa whoa wait a second why
would they be translated into French I
thought Renee Descartes was French well
yes but he actually wrote in Latin and
then eventually you know some of the
works like the meditations for example
would get translated from Latin into
French because that was a you know
common thing at the time so Descartes is
um you know available in in many many
different formats I've just got a few of
my own here just to give you a little
idea about it so I've got a couple okay
I've got more French stuff than I have
English here
um you know here's here's one from press
University Terra de France the meditate
meditation metaphysique which is a a
nice one and this one is actually the
same basically as this other press
University Terre de France version that
I have in that it has both the French
and the Original Latin so these are
really handy things to get your mitts
around here's the discourse on method
with lots and lots of footnotes and
stuff like that even some illustrations
this is a another you know petite
classic Bordeaux right uh here's the
passion de Lam the passions of the the
soul the emotions of the soul and you
know here's another one that I I have
and I think I got this one basically
when I was uh supposed to teach an intro
to philosophy class this was the
assigned textbook here's a discourse on
the method from Oxford World Classics
you can find like every publisher who
publishes academic philosophy who's
gotten into the game with translations
I'm you know kind of partial to hack it
in part because hacket translations are
usually you know well sourced and
they're also usually pretty cheap that's
one of the missions of Hackett as a
press now if you want to go further into
studying Descartes you may in fact
invest in getting yourself one of the
you know complete works sets and there
is a you know standard reference in
French the Adam and Tannery
Descartes right but you know you're
probably not reading French so you you
might want to say well what should I get
for English and there is an older
haldane and Ross 1911 uh complete works
but a lot of a lot of problems with that
which brought about the uh publication
well the project and publication of
these two there's actually a third
volume which is all the correspondence
philosophical writings of Descartes
volume 1 translated by three great
Descartes Scholars John Cottingham
Robert
stuttoff and dougold Murdoch and and
these volumes which are a little bit on
the pricey side you know to get all
three of them you're talking about about
150 bucks or so
these contain the works and these are
these are the translations that if
you're going to be a Descartes scholar
or do you know academic writing on
Descartes you're probably going to be
referencing these so you know if you
want to study Descartes you might invest
in getting this or you might just get
your hands on the hacket or as I
mentioned go to a library you don't
necessarily need to buy anything and you
know you might say well isn't one
translation better than the other yes
yes that that's quite true but you could
compare translations if you want to and
there aren't any that I've come across
where I'm like well this is atrociously
bad so you know you can begin with
what's available there's many uh that
you can easily access online including
you can even find sound files of people
reading Descartes works not just in
audible or places like that where you
have to pay for it but in LibriVox so
there's a vast variety of Cartesian
texts available to you that you uh
might want to check out now
um there's you know going to be some
difference between the translations
again you might want to compare them to
each other but you don't need to be
overly worried about having the right
translation early on at this stage in
the game as a matter of fact you might
look forward to getting to read
alternate translations down the line or
perhaps even learning French or Latin so
you can read Descartes in his original
now that we have a general question
about texts out of the way it's natural
that you're going to ask a different
question all right which text should I
begin with OR are there multiple texts
that I should or could begin with and if
we're approaching things in a completely
chronological fashion then we probably
would would say well you should begin
with this work that not too many people
actually read called the rules for the
direction of the Mind actually when I
took my day card class in graduate
school that is what we did in fact begin
with but that's probably not the best
place for you to begin and why not well
because Descartes deliberately wrote two
Works to introduce his ideas to
audiences and those are probably the
best places to begin with and so one of
them is called the discourse on method
this is one that he actually did write
in French so that he could reach not
just a learned audience but also you
know women and servants and everybody
else who could read French right and
that's a that's a great work I I teach
that in my classes undergraduates really
do respond to it because there's a cool
narrative within it we'll talk about
that in a bit and then you know a little
bit more ambitious you could say the
meditations on first philosophy still a
very accessible book though I would say
although you know there are some
difficulties to it that requires some
maybe explanation or assistance or some
attentiveness on the part of the reader
so those are usually the ones that I
start people out with and I actually
think it's great to read both of them
you know maybe the discourse first
and the reason I would say the discourse
first is because Descartes in it tells
you the story of his own education his
own development up until that point and
then he starts giving you a lot of his
sort of standard ideas and arguments and
distinctions the meditations is also a
narrative text but it goes into a bit
more detail about certain matters there
are some things that are talked about by
the way in the discourse that don't
really make it into the meditations for
example Descartes uh speculations about
human beings and animals and machines
and what is it that makes us really
human as as thinkers right but there's a
lot of overlap between the two and in
both of them you're getting really key
Cartesian ideas these are the texts too
by the way that are most often rap
referenced by people who are responding
to reacting to it reinterpreting
Descartes bringing him into a
conversation oftentimes to reject his
point of view so those are the two works
that I would say you know are great to
start out with and then you might say
all right well what do I where do I go
after that what do I read next and I I
think you've got a lot of different
possibilities the first thing I would
say is of course reread those texts
reread the discourse reread the uh
meditations but after that it depends on
where you want to go so if you're
looking for things that are you know
kind of structured in that way then you
might go back to the rules for the
direction of the mind and you might also
consider reading a later work that
Descartes intended to be something of a
textbook it was actually quite common in
the early modern period to try to
produce something that would work as a
textbook to replace the Aristotle and
you know perhaps Thomas Aquinas or other
things that they were using as textbooks
for philosophy in other cases so rules
for the direction of the mind and
principles of philosophy you learn more
about Descartes mindset system arguments
he's approaching quite a few of the same
topics but sometimes in alternate ways
in those two another thing you might
consider digging into and this is a
little bit more historical
curiosity so Descartes
had a book which he was working on when
Galileo was condemned and because
Descartes had used some Galilean stuff
in there he actually withdrew it from
publication it was in the process of
being published and he's like whoa hold
off on that buddy right and it was
called the world now along with the
discourse on method Descartes actually
published some of his essays that were
drawn from the world so you know you've
got the Optics the meteorology There's A
Treatise on man and those can all be
quite interesting to dig into as well
those you know not so influential you
could say on Descartes own
contemporaries or later thinkers but
they will get reference and it's a way
of figuring out what was this guy up to
another book that I think is very well
worth reading as a matter of fact it
would be the third book that I actually
have my students engage with and I've
taught it in the past is the passions of
the Soul which is written quite late
it's about uh philosophy of emotion and
the Mind Body Connection and there's
some ethics in there as well he wrote it
in part as a culmination of of you know
having uh correspondence with Princess
Elizabeth of bohemia who's one of
Descartes more important
correspondence and a brilliant thinker
in her own right a tragic story to her
her life and her family but Descartes
certainly recognized her and uh you know
wrote this this great work so that may
be one that's quite fun to do it's a
fairly short and speaking of
Correspondence you might find your way
into reading Descartes correspondence
not just with Princess Elizabeth but
with all sorts of other people in
particular early this this guy who was
at the center of an entire network of
intellectuals in Paris uh Marin marcen
who is is a quite important not as an
original philosopher himself but as
somebody who makes a lot of connections
the other thing that I would mention is
if you do read the meditations there are
uh along with them the objections and
replies now you could read the
meditations originally without reading
the objections and replies
it's worth spending time to read those
they and they include a couple famous
people that you probably will recognize
Thomas Hobbes uh you know Pierre gas
Sandy you know which we usually think
about in terms of uh gases and physics
and stuff like that I guess Sunday was a
Epicurean priest and he wrote to
Descartes and there were some other you
know interesting objections and
Descartes wrote his reply sometimes a
little bit testy in those so those
that's like the range of his stuff you
begin with the discourse and the uh you
know meditations maybe add in the the
passions of the soul and then it's where
you want to go and you could select one
thing for one year of study and go on to
another thing some other time that's
entirely up to you but I would advise
beginning with the discourse and the
meditations
so as you're getting ready to study
Descartes hopefully I'm trying to make a
case to you why you should and how you
could
you might want to have in mind what
Descartes was up to every philosopher
writes their philosophy not just because
they want to make some contribution to
human thought per se in an abstract
sense but because they have some real
definite ideas in mind what they they
want to do and so the first thing that
I'll say I mentioned marenderson and
said that he was part of an entire
network Descartes is writing in a
context he is not just sort of like as
he kind of presents it like starting
from complete Beginnings no if you look
at the discourse he tells you that he
had a certain education which he sees
some flaws with he tries to determine
whether he can come up with a better
approach himself he remains quite
indebted to
pre-cartesian pre-modern philosophy as a
matter of fact this is a interesting
little work that I have here called the
index scholastico cartasia by atiangel
song with a great historian of
philosophy of the 20th century and you
know it's got all these great entries
it's all in French of course in Latin uh
about ideas that that Descartes brings
up for example you God right and so you
see all these things where
Descartes is actually bringing up things
that are coming up in Thomas Aquinas or
uh in Suarez you know or
um uh this guy uh San Paulo right
um and and so you know there's there's
all sorts of interesting matters here
and uh it's quite good that um that uh
Jill song sketched this out because it
removes the idea that Descartes is
coming out of nowhere and as a matter of
fact he is writing to the people of his
time uh not just the average person on
the street but a whole bunch of Scholars
and church people and you know generally
interested lay people like I mentioned
princess Elizabeth as well right so
that's good to keep in mind Descartes is
writing to an audience that isn't quite
us but includes these other people who
we could perhaps relate to he is now on
the other hand proposing to
provide us with a a new orientation in
philosophy and you know he talks about
this in the discourse if you read it
he's looking for a solid foundation that
he doesn't feel his education which
included studying philosophy and other
fields provided him with and so you know
he thinks that he needs to come up with
this on his own and he thinks that he's
succeeded in it he wants to communicate
that to the rest of us and whether he
succeeded or not you have to read it and
find out don't take somebody else's word
for it read the actual text and see what
they have to say now the third thing
that I'll mention is that he has a
metaphor which I think is very
helpful for understanding why he's doing
things the way he is why he's so
interested in having a foundation that
we can be absolutely certain about why
he's making the distinction between body
and extension what can be mathematized
and understood through physics or other
things and the human mind which you know
escapes those sorts of things and that
is he's got this uh analogy to a tree at
the very bottom the roots and the
beginning of the trunk that is
metaphysics if you can get the
metaphysics down right then everything
else is going to follow and then the
trunk itself is going to be physics and
so you know looking at the actual world
and then it's going to have branches and
the three big branches are three M's one
of which is what he calls mechanics
which is what we call technology and so
Descartes thinks that you know applying
his method and getting rid of all the
other stuff that gets in the way is
going to lead to a scientific World in
which we can develop the kind of
technology that you and I basically take
for granted
another branch is morals Descartes
thinks that we can in fact have an
Ethics he doesn't provide you with any
sort of systematic ethics although
there's plenty of spots in his Works
where he does set out portions of an
ethics and he has a provisional morality
as well and so he thinks that we can
make progress in this and then finally
medicine now why medicine why is that so
important well you know Descartes
actually studied medicine
he got a degree in it and he was very
interested in how bodies worked he was
fascinated for example with the new
theories of the circulation of the blood
that you're going to find discussed in
discourse part five right uh he's he's
very interested as are many of the early
modern philosophers like Thomas Hobbes
or you know uh Benedict Spinoza in
explaining how the body works and how
the body is connected up with the mind
so medicine would include you know the
physical body and all of its adaptations
it would also include psychology as well
and so which I suppose you could say
also fits into tomorrow so that's that's
another key aspect of his motivations
his project he does in fact have an
Ethics that you can derive from his work
of the use of our minds and how we ought
to live Our Lives as I mentioned it's
not systematically presented but you can
re-constitute it by reading across his
Works uh and and you know connecting the
dots so to speak so that's that's part
of what's going on with him and he
appears to have been a pretty decent
human being in many respects
um he's not you know particularly
prideful or greedy or lecherous or
anything like that and then we can
um you know talk about the question well
what is really distinctive to us human
beings for Descartes we are thinking
things we're not our bodies our bodies
are a very nice complicated set of tools
that work together to further what it is
that we want to do and I'm pointing at
my brain although that's not you know
that's only a juncture point for
Descartes it's not where the soul or the
Mind resides because the mind isn't
extended it isn't bodily for a Descartes
and so figuring out reflexively as we
say there's an entire tradition of
French reflexive philosophy that
sometimes takes its inspiration from
Descartes as well as from other thinkers
our minds are thinking what our minds
are we're trying to determine that and
that's part of determining what our
human nature is and you might not accept
Descartes own point of view on this as
being you know perhaps too
individualistic or right ignoring the
connections with other minds or Souls
but he is certainly putting forth a very
interesting well-worth engaging point of
view on that so those are some of his
motivations not the totality of them but
you can say that he is somebody who
feels the need to you know respond to
critics and present things in a way that
other people can understand them and I
think that's that's an admirable trait
on his part
with Renee descarta can give you some
advice that is based on the format or
responding to the format of his works
and let's begin with the discourse and
the meditations each of these is divided
into parts that you should look at as
you know a separate part you don't want
to try to blaze your way through these
you know if you're like uh the kind of
person who's into speed reading you want
to put that aside when it comes to any
sort of deep thinker like Descartes
because otherwise you're going to pass
over too much and miss the connections
with what he's saying within texts and
to to other matters right thinking about
how it would apply to yourself so the
discourse is set up with providing a
kind of like explanation of his
imperfect education then trying to
derive what the method is going to to be
there's two sections working on that and
then there's the arguments you know what
what does the method actually yield when
we put it into play and we go all the
way through to the end with that sort of
thing the meditations are designed to
work a little bit differently they are
indeed meditations
and this doesn't mean that you go off in
the corner and you know turn the lights
down low and you know start you know
sitting in Lotus position and you know
monitoring your breathing yeah I mean
you can do it sitting in a chair like
this you just read and think about what
you're reading and don't try to jump
ahead
really think it over I mean ideally you
could take six days when you're reading
the meditations because that's the way
they're designed to first you know read
one and think about those matters and
see what our narrator Descartes uh has
to say and think about what thoughts it
provokes in you then go on and pick it
up the next day and then go on and pick
it up the next day that's a great way to
approach these these things and it's you
know it's right there in the format of
the works I mean if you want to sit
there and read the whole thing in one
setting nobody's gonna stop you right
but you might find that you've missed a
few things along the way
you you want to approach every one of
his works as if it is a separate work
with its own kind of genre there are
similarities between them right there's
sections and things are numbered and you
you know he develops things kind of uh
methodically systematically
um there will be digressions where he's
like well let's talk about this now
coming back to the point but you know
you're probably familiar with that in
philosophers but don't expect the rules
for the direction of the mind to be
exactly like the discourse or the
passions of the soul to be exactly like
the principles of philosophy or the
meditations to be like other meditations
that you've seen take them each as what
they are and explore the structure that
he puts there
um you might also want to try to as best
you can it's very difficult to do check
your preconceptions the things that you
think you know about Descartes at the
door and this includes stupid jokes like
you know the bartender has somebody walk
in and a state card and uh you know he's
asked a question and Descartes says I
don't think so and then he disappears
that's just silly that people
do you know to make memes and all that
put those things aside put whatever
Monty Python thing you've ever come
across put the uh memes and and you know
uh reconstructions put also put aside
scholarly disputes with Descartes uh
coming from people who you've read who
think they know everything there is to
know about Descartes right don't worry
about that crap that's not something
that is going to help you read the text
see what's actually in front of you and
then you can come back to that stuff
later right the other thing that I think
is really quite important
go into these texts
aware that the use of language
has sometimes changed from Descartes
time to our own and the translations are
you know trying to Faithfully render
what he's saying so for example in
meditation three there's a really
important discussion there about
objective reality and you know he
contrasts that to formal or eminent
reality and when we talk about objective
reality we think about what's out there
what's what's not an idea but what is a
real thing right
while Descartes means that as the object
of the Mind as an idea right the amount
of reality that something has as an idea
so you've got to be attentive
to the shifts in language and that's
where perhaps
um having resources might help you out
so that you don't get tripped up
similarly there's other terms that you
know they're not completely changed in
meaning in that way like where it means
it's opposite but where you know uh
things could be a bit different than
what you imagine them to be when you run
into something you're like that doesn't
make any sense well that might be a
matter of that terminology the other
thing about language that I think could
be helpful for you to keep in mind is
that although Descartes
often disclaims engaging in any rhetoric
you know he's not trying to pull the
wool over your eyes he's not trying to
convince you without having good
arguments he is also a master
rhetorician the way the works are set up
the way in which he proceeds the sort of
things that he says offhandedly show you
that he really does know how to use
language well to his advantage and so
you know you want to be kind of attuned
to that some of the works this is more
of an issue than others the meditations
is particularly
crafty in terms of its rhetorical
construction so you might want to be
attuned to and attentive to that so that
I think that's enough of the advice the
only other thing I'll mention is that
there there are you know secondary
sources out there that can be helpful
there's like a a vast world of articles
about Descartes encyclopedia entries and
you know some of the ones are pretty
good you'll also find books like these
two where you know
I particularly like these this is why I
have them you know some some great uh
sets of essays you know Amelie rorty is
you know a brilliant editor and thinker
in her own right John Cottingham he's
the guy who along with the others train
you know provided the sort of official
translation and so you know you look at
these sorts of things there's also like
you know Rutledge Companions and stuff
like that and there'll be you know a
bunch of articles that go into depth
that connecting the dots that I told you
about these are by Scholars who really
have thought a lot about Descartes and
his his texts and his claims and
arguments so you might find going to
something like this you know helpful
from from time to time that's less about
the format of the work and more about
you know Finding useful guides or things
like that so that's probably it as far
as advice on format
as always with the sort of advice that I
have about how to engage in
self-directed study there are going to
be some problems some issues some
matters that you could raise that I
think at the beginning you probably
don't want to worry about too much you
you know would do a lot better to put
those aside for the moment as something
you can come back to later on and just
see what Descartes is actually saying go
along for the ride so to speak so what
are these well the first one is is
Descartes totally right about every
single thing that he says nobody is no
philosopher is don't worry about that
don't uh get yourself too worked up when
you find something that you object to
first of all you may not actually be
understanding things correctly but even
if you are and Descartes wrong about one
thing it doesn't mean that the entire
system falls down you know uh I mean you
could say well that's not fair because
Descartes himself is saying things like
that sure sure that's the methodological
doubt but you don't even know if
methodological doubt itself works and so
that that leads to another thing
don't worry about whether you truly can
doubt everything Descartes doesn't doubt
everything this is part of his
rhetorical construction pay attention to
what he's doing with his doubt what the
point of the hyperbolic or
methodological doubt actually is and
this extends to worrying about oh man
are we in a simulation is this like the
Matrix deccurred isn't saying that
that's the case at all you know that's
what uh you could say second rate pop
philosophers will focus in on but that's
only a tiny tiny little portion of what
the guy is actually interested in any
gets rid of those worries right he
addresses those those concerns and by
the end of the discourse and by the end
of the uh you know meditations he's
already addressed that and he sure isn't
worried about that in the passions of
the Soul or some of the the other works
where he's already taking for granted
that we do in fact know things
I think another thing to not make a huge
issue of where like you have to take a
stand dualism of body and mind right you
may or may not buy into that you may if
you do buy into dualism you might think
that Descartes wrong about that you know
for for example the pineal gland being
the juncture where brain and mind come
together that's all fine don't worry
over much about that again try to figure
out what the guy is actually saying what
he's committing to the distinction that
he is making between body and so you
know extended substance mind thought
substance and then of course there's
there's God as a third pretty much
unknown substance try to pay attention
to what he's actually developing about
the mind and also if you disagree with
his theory of the emotions or his
psychology that's all fine but that
doesn't have to get in the way of you
actually developing and understanding
you know first in philosophy comes
understanding then agreement is
something we worry about after we we
fully understand same thing with
appreciation you don't have to like
Descartes you don't have to find him as
enjoyable to read as I do but if you do
want to understand him that's your goal
the last thing that I would say you
don't really need to worry about at this
point
is Descartes views on God right
Descartes certainly brings God in to
some of his discussions
um and there is this thing we call the
Cartesian Circle where God is part of
the justification for why we can
actually rely upon our thoughts and
ultimately our senses right God not
being a deceiver but you don't really
have to worry too much about his
theology or his point of view on that
hearing him talk about God don't
automatically assume that he's a
Christian in any robust substantive
sense that was something that he got
criticized for by other thinkers in his
own time like Blaise Pascal right
Descartes God is essentially the god of
deism it you know he gets the universe
going we don't really know much about
him he structures things in certain ways
but Descartes very much focused on this
world and understanding how our minds
and bodies work in this world itself so
I wouldn't worry too much about that
um and that's that's probably enough now
I mentioned that you know you can get
secondary literature great you know uh
collections
anthologies of essays and you're going
to find people you know worrying about
that sort of thing in there like you
know here's a chapter on the kojito and
its Imports kojito means I think right
well what is the Cartesian kojito it's
not just I think it's also I doubt I
will I will against all these other
mental acts that are that are in there
did he get the list completely right
well you know that's what these people
might argue about but at the beginning
you don't have to worry too much about
that sort of stuff so I think you can
set aside some of these problems issues
concerns not that you can't come back to
them later on not that you can't
register them you might even want to
write them down somewhere for yourself
but in your initial
um actually not just initial but you
know your first several
meanders through the Cartesian texts
just try to see what the guy is actually
saying where he's going and then worry
about whether you agree with it 100
later on
so final thoughts I'll come back to
where I began saying Descartes is really
somebody that you ought to read you know
there's probably quite a few figures
where you can take them or leave them
you don't necessarily have to read them
in order to have a good background in
philosophy Descartes is not one of those
thinkers whether you agree with him
disagree with them love him hate him are
indifferent to him
he really is somebody that if you're
going to study philosophy in any sort of
well thought out systematic
more or less adequate way you want to
know who he is you want to at least read
the discourse and the meditations maybe
the passions of the Soul maybe you'll go
on to other things as well maybe you
choose to read some of the secondary
literature but he's certainly well worth
spending the time on uh fortunately
there's lots and lots of resources out
there that can help you study Descartes
successfully I myself have produced uh
videos and podcast episodes covering the
entirety of the discourse and the
meditations so that might be helpful for
you there's lots of other people who've
done similar stuff but you know all of
that is is nice as an adjunct to you
actually spending some time with this
great early thinker of what we nowadays
call Modern he's often considered to be
one of the fathers of modern philosophy
but it goes beyond that he's one of the
fathers of the modern world and so I
think that you're going to find it's
really well worth your time to engage
with him you will if you put in the
requisite time attention and work you
are definitely going to get something
out of it and I'll end here that feels
good when you study philosophy and you
can take something home you've got
something up in your head that you can
communicate to others and even apply in
real life